salamualikum' how you guys doing amazing
it just so captivating
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I just met some incredible people a
mother and her son got a little daughter
here I'll let them take it from here
after I just kind of do sick sheiks up
this little buddy a year and a half ago
that's the power of sharing she
connected with the message on the
Selassie mission to the crater meant to
creation she accepted his launch came
from a Christian background and then her
son just today right now took Shahada
[Music]
[Applause]
he was also really captivated by the
message heaven let them introduce
themselves you ready my name is Dan that
what was it what was it about Islam how
long ago did you accept it and what was
it about Islam that captivated you that
captured your heart
now
now let's verify
we left oh my god
who wasn't that told you about us time
I
of course let's get on to my dad
levels
in
so now your son how does this happen
today you know for those that not yet
Muslims out there you're wondering how
does someone except slow they give birth
to what's already inside them it's
inside all of us the potential to submit
to surrender to the greater not to
creation you take that testimonial thing
that you declared there's nothing worthy
of worship they're not going to wish the
man a war man is saying a dead person in
the ground sticker stone nothing but the
creator of the heavens and earth and
Mohammed is the last one I'm not sure
this would include that Xcode all the
preceding messengers cluding Jesus
Abraham Moses they all brought the same
message submission to the world
not the creation nothing other than the
one who created you today you said your
mom was a great impact light my initial
my initial introduction
like formal introduction to Islam was
actually in college
what happened was that I was actually it
was interesting because I was actually
part of a trip to Peru
there was a time
a group was inviting speakers from
different religions and for one at one
of the weeks we had
and the same organization from from our
College
and they brought an imam to speak
from that moment and that was in the
year 2000 call
like a little bit of
but they never really got around to
actually because I still had a lot of
fun
in my heart
[Music]
you know basically tonight
[Music]
some of those questions were answered by
some brothers that I talked with
I decided that a lot
question before
you know that
[Music]
I realized the battery at the end of the
day at the earning matter
I have certain
the common one that a lot of people who
struggle with it again
if there is a loving God why is your
father
these are issues that even now I stopped
but I'm today tonight I realize you know
what like
questions are never going to be answer
like
I might as well take the
take the pain
I realized that
[Music]
like ideally at the end of the date like
and I get these are questions that won't
mark they're not use the game
[Music]
I realized
it's better for me
[Music]
well welcome notice what about the
divinity of Jesus you talk to me about
about that part yeah I mean initially
initially that wasn't
at the beginning it looks like I did a
lot of
back in poorer
one of the wanted
the things that I
because cancer get Bernie was the Old
Testament
you know verses verses in the Bible
that's
Hiroki throw your goddess
stuff like that and I realized that I
realized that Islam is consistent with
that
the first commandment
- not working I realize that
a lot of their stuff they're competing
some parts of Christianity like for
example the Catholic Church they have
like their statues others think of their
senses though and like I realize that
contradictory to the First Amendment
[Music]
those were themes there I looked at
things like logically and I
I looked at the Hilton
and I realize that well
[Music]
that convinced me
that's more what your what
[Music]
how did you feel not today this year to
see your son take the Shahada to accept
Islam how did it feel
and what
I know that God
[Music]
I've made the way
today I was
I know that Marvin has been fair
here in London
at one time he was even invited
[Music]
Antonia was
[Music]
humanity
that
I am
all the builders
how was it that's amazing so she was on
the market the call to prayer you were
learning it or they were helping you
with hit I I was visited I was visiting
a local
[Music]
and
Imam there shows me her from
to the Common Prayer
the time obviously I wasn't
I hadn't taken Shahada yet so I
do it or that I
[Music]
someone's thinking like why did he call
you if you know if you how did he if you
didn't know how to do it why would he
call you yeah yeah that was my question
like like what look like why I was
thinking that why why would he forget he
thought you all he thought you were my
okay I see oh and that's like you took
it like a sign Oh amazing last but not
the least this is your daughter how are
you what do you think of all this is
going on you saw your brother up you saw
your you saw your brother thousands of
people thousands of people taking his
Shahada you like man what's going on
what were you what were your thoughts an
impression
[Music]
[Music]
I see that your your your mimicking your
mom you start wearing the little job you
know who else wore the hijab you know
who Jesus is right you know his mother
Mary you heard of Mary she used to wear
hijab that's what they're mimicking
thank you guys a wonderful family this
is amazing you know the God Almighty is
the most merciful and he sent guidance
do you want guidance ask for it it's
very simple within yourself I mean we're
here for a purpose
and everything around you had a purpose
the keys in your pocket pocket our
purpose your shoelaces have a purpose
the tie right here has a purpose to suit
everything around to us what about food
the human being you don't have a purpose
who best to tell you your purpose and
then the one who created you for a
purpose but ask ask me you shall receive
ask the one who created you what's my
purpose why am I here guide me guide me
of all the confusion out there the way
that God would my
had prescribed for us has to be simple
and that simple message is to worship
him alone and not his creation and he
will facilitate a way cuz he loves you
call us if you have any questions 1 800
662 Islam we're here to help facilitate
the way and answer any questions that
you might have we'll see you next time
so I'm making peace with you
[Applause]